because I want to ask you a couple of questions.
I think many here, and in general in Western countries,
would agree with your statement about analysis
of democratic systems becoming dysfunctional,
but at the same time, many would kind of find
unsettling the thought that there is an unelected
authority that, without any form of oversight or consultation,
decides what the national interest is.
What is the mechanism in the Chinese model
that allows people to say, actually,
the national interest as you defined it is wrong?
EXL: You know, Frank Fukuyama, the political scientist,
called the Chinese system "responsive authoritarianism."
It's not exactly right, but I think it comes close.
So I know the largest public opinion survey company
in China, okay?
Do you know who their biggest client is?
The Chinese government.
Not just from the central government,
the city government, the provincial government,
to the most local neighborhood districts.
They conduct surveys all the time.
Are you happy with the garbage collection?
Are you happy with the general direction of the country?
So there is, in China, there is a different kind of mechanism
to be responsive to the demands and the thinking of the people.
My point is, I think we should get unstuck
from the thinking that there's only one political system --
election, election, election --
that could make it responsive.
I'm not sure, actually, elections produce
responsive government anymore in the world.
(Applause)
BG: Many seem to agree.
One of the features of a democratic system
is a space for civil society to express itself.
And you have shown figures about the support
that the government and the authorities have in China.
But then you've just mentioned other elements
like, you know, big challenges, and there are, of course,
a lot of other data that go in a different direction:
tens of thousands of unrests and protests
and environmental protests, etc.
So you seem to suggest the Chinese model
doesn't have a space outside of the Party
for civil society to express itself.
EXL: There's a vibrant civil society in China,
whether it's environment or what-have-you.
But it's different. You wouldn't recognize it.
Because, by Western definitions, a so-called civil society
has to be separate or even in opposition
to the political system,
but that concept is alien for Chinese culture.
For thousands of years, you have civil society,
yet they are consistent and coherent
and part of a political order, and I think
it's a big cultural difference.
BG: Eric, thank you for sharing this with TED. EXL: Thank you.